this video is brought to you by ren
[Music]
what's up guys helen here to talk about
tv's oddest
greatest buddy comedy rick and morty the
show has long reveled in absurdity and
so crazy it's brilliant creativity
still its latest offering rick and
morty's thankspointation spectacular
managed to surprise us with a bizarre
plot featuring plenty of turkey on
turkey violence
blueberries we got blueberries down hold
your positions at the feeding frame
i can't see but is there any depth
beneath all the foul play
get it foul play like a bird we think so
and we'd argue it has everything to do
with the show calling bs on america's
own self-mythologizing we'll explain in
this wisecrack quick take on rick and
morty
why thanksgiving is a lie but before we
get into it i want to give a shout out
to this video sponsor
ren now i don't know about you guys but
the constant bad news about climate
change
sucks and the worst part is that i feel
like there's nothing i can do about it
and this is where ren comes in rent is a
website that helps you calculate your
carbon footprint and then
shows you how you can offset your
footprint by funding projects that do
things like plant trees and protect
rainforests
rather than just feeling bad about the
climate crisis with ren
you can actually do something about it
all without having to spend all day
outside getting sweaty and dirty while
planting trees
all you have to do is answer a few
questions about your lifestyle and wren
will calculate your carbon footprint and
help you reduce it now as much as i've
tried
no one can reduce their carbon footprint
to zero but you can offset what you have
left after reducing it on your own
because you're already trying to reduce
your carbon footprint on your own right
once you sign up to make a monthly
contribution that will be used to offset
your carbon footprint
you'll receive monthly updates from the
projects you support they'll actually
send you pictures of trees that you
planted so you can see what your money
was spent on
and i mean who doesn't want pictures of
beautiful trees showing up on their
inbox
we all know it's going to take a lot of
work to slow down the climate crisis
so why not start today we've partnered
with ren to protect five extra acres of
rainforest for the first 100 people who
sign up using our referral link
so go to www.ren.comwisecrack to join us
in saving the rainforest and fighting
the climate crisis
that's ren dot co join slash wisecrack
and now back to the show so what is this
episode functionally doing
at first glance it's pretty simple
roasting america's history
and with that it's present there's the
statue of liberty secretly being a
trojan horse concealing a steam-powered
assassin or fdr as a spider creature
thanks to a bad vaccine
side note please get vaccinated my dudes
you won't turn into a subterranean
spider human
i promise anyway no venerated aspect of
american history or
present is exempt from the show's
irreverence especially not its
presidents
don't mythologize him he was a
politician or its congressman
president curtis has enacted a plan to
turn all turkeys in america
into hybrid super soldiers the move has
100 approval from congress following its
third pay raise in six hours
or its favorite bird centric holiday and
on america's birthday or whatever the
thanksgiving is now you don't have to be
history's biggest devil's advocate to
understand where the show is coming from
american history has
famously been edited polished up and at
times
straight up turned into mythology in
fact the early days of american studies
from the 1930s to the 50s were dominated
by the so-called
myth and symbol school it as you might
guess
looked for myths and symbols that
allegedly attested to the specificity
or even uniqueness of the u.s as scholar
ike paul writes in her book the myths
that made america
this effort was undertaken as scholar
donald ep's notes
in search of historical confirmations of
the nation's unique
mission and destiny in this way america
built a discourse establishing itself
as what scholar bernd ostendorf calls a
consciously constructed
new world utopia that is we got pretty
comfy believing that we were doing
something entirely new and totally
radical
that's of course the perspective plenty
of the joke characters in the episode
embody
that little race car driver you got
bacon in your belly what world you want
him rearing up in
one where some spiky-haired doctor who
in a lab coat can change the color of
the sky
or a world where he can fill his pickup
with hot dogs and drive it to a jukebox
full of our demographic's current
favorite music
that said according to folks like
scholar john coakley
myth no matter how powerful it's not
enough to form a national ideology on
its own
it needs two side dishes one is rituals
like funerals
military parades or um turkey pardonings
which serve to remind people vividly of
their membership in a community
existing over time and the other is
symbols lots of symbols
especially objects ranging from coins to
flags to posters of rosie the riveter
which exists to elicit emotions in a
community's members
all of this together constitutes what
sociologist robert bella
way back in 1967 called america's
elaborate and well-instituted civil
religion
here civil religion means a collection
of beliefs drawing partly from religion
to create powerful symbols of national
solidarity
symbols that you know we might not want
to see blown up in space
why don't we just blow it up the
national monument now
of course there's nothing inherently
wrong with building national solidarity
but these myths rituals and symbols i.e
this civil religion
shapes the way we view everything from
our presidents to our architecture to
our army
and in fact religious scholar charles h
long argues
that america's civil religion breeds a
kind of historical selectivity and blind
faith in our
innate goodness at its worst this can
allow us to ignore and even perpetuate
major social ills
like racism and that's pretty clearly
what rick and morty is making fun of we
see the way america's mythos is
propagated through cultural products
like the country song which convinces
all the soldiers that now it's time to
turn into
a turkey here evoking america's
down-home country goodness
successfully wrangles an army despite
the fact that these guys are really just
fighting at the behest of a president
engaged in a petty feud jesus ever
loving christ why don't you two just
get it over with or the way evoking
country musician johnny cash and race
car driver dale earnhardt in a political
speech
helps lure these men back into the
turkey war what would johnny cash or
dale earnhardt say
he'd say it's time to walk the line or
drive very fast between two of them now
some of our american mythologizing was
born out of cultural necessity colonial
america had to essentially create a past
and a national character from scratch in
part to divorce themselves from
britain's storied national mythology
as scholar henry stokomager explained
nothing in the history of american
nationalism
is more impressive than the speed and
the lavishness
with which americans provided themselves
with a usable past
history legends symbols paintings
sculpture
monuments shrines holy days ballads
patriotic songs
heroes and with some difficulty villains
we see this cultural iconography roundly
degraded throughout rick and morty's
patriotic roasting
even the villain part here mocked in the
constant refrain about
terrorists you know you use that word so
much it's lost all meaning mr p
as paul writes even as we have come a
long way since the beginnings of the
myth and symbol school
the entanglements between historical
myth and contemporary ideology
are as complex as they have ever been we
see this in the way one soldier before
being turkified
evokes a noble call to duty that sounds
like world war ii era propaganda
that world needs a few good men in a
secret pentagon lab
turning into turkeys at the same time
the show critiques the far
less savory realities of modern american
warfare
which are often left out of the
mainstream discourse whose side are we
on
i don't know but we've done enough to
pay for college in the post-credits
scene
we even see a veteran suffering from
blueberry induced ptsd
and lacking adequate health care shrug
off the president's failure to help him
in his fault our insurance got cut i got
to build missiles but before you go and
pick up a canadian passport
it's worth pointing out america isn't
alone in its proclivity for myth-making
every country relies on cultural mythos
for reasons we'll get into there's the
way composer richard wagner's operas
were used to rally german patriotism
during hitler's reign
or the way writer alexander pushkin
helped define russianness after the
napoleonic wars
and even the way history is told foster
strong national identities
this makes sense history as its practice
today
grew out of 19th century academia a
deeply nationalist period of western
history
when countries like italy and germany
were uniting several regional states
under one national flag while countries
like greece
serbia and poland participated in
revolutionary uprisings against the
ottoman and russian empires the result
was that each country pretty much
developed their own specific nationalist
history and that includes america's
conception of itself within the 17th
century puritanical paradigm
of an explicitly christian city on a
hill while these national perspectives
have certainly been called into question
by many historians
it hasn't vanished from the field as
historian e.j hobbs bomb explained back
in 1992
historians without a past are
contradictions in terms what
makes a nation is the past what
justifies one nation against others is
the past and historians are the people
who produce the past
now the fields of history and american
studies have both in recent decades
been complicated by new schools of
thought that question these prevailing
narratives
for rick and morty's part summer pipes
up at one point sharing a far more
skeptical perspective about american
history oh wow wiping out a native
population on thanksgiving that's never
happened before
what did you just say still the show
argues that much of the nationalist
myths propagated over centuries
continue to stick around in our cultural
psyche rick and morty also suggest that
the resulting mythologies many of us
share about america
are just as random and absurd as the
idea that thanksgiving was won by alien
pilgrims and native americans who
secretly
got along no wait they love each other
this moment might also be explicitly
critiquing the very real mythos about
thanksgiving
which posits peaceful corn-sharing
relations between white settlers and
native americans
rather than you know a lot of genocide
overall the episode's own american
mythology escalates into absurdity
is that a turkey dinosaur in this way it
draws into sharp relief the absurdity of
our own real life myths about cherry
trees and productive fair trade between
white settlers and native americans
oh not to mention the intended sacrilege
of releasing a thanksgiving special
in july but why do we as societies like
sharing myth after myth after myth
that is to say what do mythologies
practically do for us as a people
at a most basic level they're necessary
for maintaining collective identity
they provide a given society with a
sense of coherence and continuity but it
goes deeper than that
scholar roland barthes argues that myth
functions literally as a sort of
language we can all share in
what historian lyla danielson describes
as a mode of communication that
disguises something that is contingent
and socially constructed as natural and
timeless that is to say
myths street america as the only
possible outcome of history
rather than as a very carefully
constructed human-made reality
and this sort of historical
mythologizing can change the way a
country feels entitled to behave
for example the sense of a timeless
exceptional america has
historically arguably made it possible
for the country to justify lots of
gnarly things
like unnecessary invasions of the middle
east or overthrowing democratically
elected governments in latin america
after all if we're the greatest our
actions must be justified right this
rick and morty episode underscores the
importance of mythology and symbols
in keeping society coherent and then
creating a shared language for our
nationalist
impulses heritage destroyed
moments like this suggest the importance
of collective symbols in sustaining
society as we know it
and at the end of the episode we also
see the risk a society faces
when its myths get busted after seeing
everything he knew about america be
upended
morty comments i always thought we were
more special than that like we invented
everything and did everything and that's
why we own everything
no i i i don't know what to feel here
he's lost the comforting language of the
mythology he was raised on
the president offers a toothless feel
thankful morty
feel thankful what morty's facing is the
destabilizing reality that america isn't
what he thought it was
it's just like any other nation built on
a foundation of myths and narratives
rather than on any real moral
exceptionalism and having had my own
mind blown listening to howard zinn's
people's history
largely because of matt damon's stellar
narration i know that's a lot for anyone
to take in
but what do you guys think did rick and
morty roast thanksgiving like it's a
prized turkey
or is there still value in our national
mythology let us know in the comments
and please don't get too angry at us big
thanks to our patrons for all your
support
hit that subscribe button like it's a
superhuman turkey warrior and don't
forget to ring that bell
and as always thanks for watching peace
[Applause]
[Music]
it